do not have impostor syndrome or moments
of insecurity just cuz you're of an age
there's plenty of people 10 years older
than you that don't know half the
you know I'm teaching a college class
good for you I have no idea what I'm
doing yes you do no I don't more than
you think yeah when you don't really
actually know what you're doing have the
humility to actually speak to that
vulnerability but when you do know what
you're doing don't be self-deprecating
and speak your truth I mean I'm
6 years younger than these kids or older
so it's like and I was 6 years older
than my friends that when I was 24 now
were 18 I was 700 years wiser in life I
was 30 years younger than a lot of my
teachers and more understood what the
was actually going on the way you
said it is why I know you're letting age
be a variable age has never had an
actual variable on most of things
besides earned wisdom yes you will earn
wisdom at 34 and 44 and 54 do not have
impostor syndrome or moments of
insecurity just cuz you're of an age
there's plenty of people 10 years older
than you that don't know half the
you know